foreign
I can tell very easily looking at
somebody
whether or not they need Network or not
if your neck kind of comes down right
where your jaw is you don't need to do a
lot of neck work yeah right you don't
look like a head placed on top of a
little neck your neck is actually you
know layered Hamilton's neck is out to
the lobes of his ears genuinely yeah
yeah Danny Way great skateboard too he
trains is not quite like broke his neck
certainly yeah yeah years ago so having
a strong neck why is that so important
well it's important because you want a
strong spine and it's the upper portion
of your spine the other thing that I
notice that it does is it completely
changes my psychology to train my neck I
just naturally stand more upright yeah I
find it easier to look people in the eye
it's not hard for me to look people
directly in the eye when I speak to them
but I find I just have like my posture
and presence is just better in a chair
or standing when I train my neck and I
think it's because my head isn't let's
just use the word again it's not you
know flaccid falling of the chin towards
the chest that word just freaks
everybody out you want flaccid feet you
don't want to floss the neck
so network is very important how do you
work in it
I actually recently bought I've been
thinking about it for decades I bought a
four-way neck machine and it's actually
I got it you got the full forward I was
gonna get like a hammer or one of these
giant Contraptions I actually bought and
look do your homework folks because you
can hurt yourself on these things if you
get too aggressive too quickly
I bought a four-way deck machine on
Amazon for 350 bucks I was like you know
what let me try this before spending
like five grand
works great yeah yeah nothing fancy but
you have to worry proportions I mean why
do I say this it's not just about
Aesthetics it's about in general balance
proportions are synonymous with balanced
strength which is synonymous with not
getting injured yeah you know one of the
things that looks ridiculous and frankly
is ridiculous to see these guys with big
delts wide shoulders you know long
clavicles and their head is placed on
this little popsicle on a stick well and
they look especially ridiculous there's
no other word for it in street clothes
yeah you see you know like this it looks
mutant
and not in the good sense so strong neck
is great strong neck has helped me also
avoid injuries in a number of sports
it's life insurance if you do anything
any kind of martial art where you drive
a car you know I've been rear-ending a
car and felt fine you know a little bit
of neck soreness but train the upper
spine and lower spine so I do some neck
work at the end and the way I do it is
take a plate wrap it in a towel so you
know with an imprint of the
weight number on your forehead and I
usually lie on my side and I'll do it
somewhere in the 10 to 15 repetition
range I'll usually do one light warm-up
and then three works out how do you hold
it on your head
with your hand on your side it also
works your obliques somewhat you're on a
bench or on the bench yeah you have to
be careful you know especially getting
into and out of the movement that's how
you often get injured and then I'll lie
on my stomach and this is probably the
most important one and I'll put the
plate behind my head again wrapped in a
towel and do
head raises so this is the opposite of
the text
neck you're trying to get your head
sitting on top of your shoulders as it's
supposed to because everyone now is kind
of bent over in this kind of C shape and
no one's nerdy enough except my good
friend Brian McKenzie who cares enough
about his posture shout out to Brian
he's amazing work and breath work and
Human Performance he when he texts he
uses his phone up near his house
no one else does that Ryan so the neck
work comes at the end but is absolutely
critical and whenever I don't do it for
a week or two out of laziness or or just
some other reason I start getting
postural things you start noticing
elsewhere in your body I find and this
could just be I don't think it's Placebo
because it's not something that I expect
or maybe it is now but not initially
fewer headaches just better circulation
yeah and
better Mobility also especially if
you're spending a lot of time in front
of a computer my my rotation
even though I'm not actively training
with resistance the rotational aspect
Left Right turning your head the
mobility of the neck sort of in all
dimensions and the movement of the head
seems to improve as well for me and for
folks just one option I want to throw
out there if you train with someone or
can train with someone manual resistance
with a towel someone said with a towel
or just like pressure on the head and
doing it really slowly like super slow
style kind of like 10 seconds 10 seconds
is very effective also I can't overstate
the importance of neck training now for
women who often don't want the aesthetic
of a larger neck yeah just use very I
would say lighter weights or or hand
based resistance you still want that
strength in balance
some women might want a big neck but in
general the two things that can and you
can put some of this Hamilton that's my
type oh it's done just putting it out
there ladies
one thing that in terms of Aesthetics
the two things that I think can really
throw off the most commonly desired
female aesthetic by women from what they
tell me because I trained with a number
of women is
excessive trap work upper trap work
because rounded shoulders and then
larger neck some people might want that
but in general that tends to be avoided
for guys I think that the network is you
know it's a it's so essential and for
women it's essential for a strength and
and protection of the joints reason I
will also say this and anyone who wants
to challenge me on this will do it
accordingly it actually increases your
confidence and the reason is when you're
upright you embody a different stance
I'm a big believer that the physical
stances we embody have everything to do
with the psychological stances we embody
and vice versa it's not just about
standing up straight being able to stand
up straight look people in the eye is
something that is assisted by actually
having a head that that isn't flopping
forward all the time oh yeah so this is
a real thing from a number of
standpoints